[Music]
we have guests matter what you know
holding off a dirty what the hell is
this good girl Stern he's a complete
mental hand I'm awfully sorry about that
but um you see he thinks it's still the
nineteen eighteen or nineteen fourteen
some right there isn't it I miss later
onset of um well robot dementia tall
pretty yeah I know you're smoking on
that pipe man what's going on here will
you drag me to some tranch for more time
at home somebody but I start talking I'm
outta here
whoa okay um bumblebee we only met when
I was a little boy in short pants I must
be that's or maybe Torah or maybe short
I can't remember but your face fee you
know this guy oh yeah it's um look at
this thing please very interesting yes
you keep a secret for so long no need to
be true and yet deep down inside you
begin to wonder has my life been wasted
have you ever felt like that mr. Cain
it's just Kate look Oh Tara I don't have
a ton of patience for riddles right now
yes but you want to know don't you dude
why they keep coming here to us right ah
I do so love perfect timing
no no money has to be that Oh
so this a kidnapping sort of situation
on her first transformer experience was
both really
she's very difficult
you